[Applaudissements]
dis-moi
l'avenir je suis
amoureux dis-moi l'avenir l'avenir
l'avenir je vais te dire l'avenir c'est
que cette chanson tuaurais pas dû la
chanter dismoi l'avenir je veux tout
savoir dis-moi que je veux garder de
l'espoir dis-moi l'avenir lis-moi dans
la main dis-moi quel parfinga mon
dessin comme un prisonnier je m'ennuie
je tourne en rond je fais des projets
sans horizon
elle m'a tout volé mon sourire et mon
soleil je n'existe plus je pense à elle
c'est là où tu te trompes elle se joue
de moi à l'oreille de moi je ne sais
plus quoi faire je suis voilà tu m'as
fait
tromper dis-moi l'avenir j'ai confiance
en toi dis-le moi et je serai fou de
joie la connais en
allem
en
allemand tu dis ça parce que tu sais
plus les paroles hein non mais ch
pas dis-moi Martino dis-moi quel est mon
avenir alors je sais pas je pas je peux
pas le dire c'est des cartes muettes ah
bon d'accord je te laisse voilà bravo
alors